foreign
thank you thank you I'm not even a
nominee but I feel like it
well welcome to the academy Museum of
Motion Pictures the largest institution
in the United States devoted to the Arts
sciences and artists of movie making the
academy Museum of Motion Pictures
acknowledges the tongva people as the
traditional caretakers of the water and
land on which we program curate educate
convene and discuss we honor and respect
tongva ancestors in the tongva community
today which continue to nurture this
land and water through traditional
practice activism art and education we
also acknowledge their continued
continued work to safeguard cultural
resources
my name is lahani cook and I'm the
manager of public engagement my pronouns
are she her and thank you for joining us
in our David Geffen Theater for the live
action shorts nominee panel presented as
a part of our Oscars week programming
before we begin the panel public
programming for the 2023 Oscar week is
made possible by the Ruderman Family
Foundation which promotes authentic
representation in the entertainment
industry and full inclusion of people
with disabilities throughout all sectors
of society I would like to thank our ASL
interpreters who will be assisting today
their names are few are felix Via Real
Paola borales Romina Mena and now please
help me in welcoming to the stage senior
vice president of member relations
Global Outreach and awards
Administration Tom oyer
hello hi everyone great to see you all
today I'm here representing Our member
relations and awards Administration team
and today we are celebrating our five
live-action short Film nominees now you
might be asking yourself how did we get
here how do we have how did these
nominees come to be so I'm just going to
give a brief rundown on the process and
how it works the first step is that
films need to qualify in order to be
eligible film has to be qualified and in
do that there are a few different ways
by which live-action short films can
qualify first method is by doing a
one-week qualifying theatrical release
in one of our qualifying cities the
second method is through our qualifying
Festival process basically the summation
of that is that our we have a list of
qualifying festivals and specific juried
Awards and the films that win those
juried awards are automatically eligible
to submit for Academy consideration the
second the third method is uh through
Student Academy Awards uh films that win
either gold silver or bronze medals at
the Student Academy Awards are also
eligible to submit from there we have
our submission the next step of the
process is the films have to submit we
have our submission process by which
they provide their films to the academy
for consideration this year we had 200
live-action short films submitted and
eligible and yes that is a record uh so
we received submitted films from all of
them oh there we go all right
a record year uh we receive our
submissions from films from all over the
world I want to give a special thank you
to Michael Benedict Lauren McPhee and
many others on our Academy team that
manage the submission process all year
round and without them this category
would not be possible so thank you
uh so then once we get our submitted
films the next step of the process is
the voting process and through that we
work with our Academy members to vote to
view the films and vote uh members from
four branches are invited to participate
their members from the short films and
feature animation Branch the director's
Branch The Producers branch and the
writer's Branch members from those four
branches are invited and then you can
opt in to participate
by doing so they are then have to watch
a certain number of films in order to be
eligible to vote and then from there
they vote in December to determine a
short list of 15 films that shortlist
was announced in December and then from
there there is a second round of voting
again members from those same branches
that can view the 15 shortlisted films
and then vote to determine the five
nominees
and now that we have our five nominees
we now open it up to the entire Academy
membership and the entire membership
votes in all 23 categories to determine
the Oscar winner in each category which
you will find out on Sunday
little show you should check out
um all right and so I want to take this
moment to really thank all the academy
members who volunteer and spend that
time to view all these films this
process would not be possible without
your work and your participation and
please know how much we all appreciate
it and we will continue asking for your
help again every year uh next it's my
pleasure to introduce to you a governor
of the short film some feature animation
Branch he's an Academy Award nominated
filmmaker previous nominee in this
category and currently in his 21st year
as a governor please welcome John blue
[Applause]
thank you everybody I want to quickly
reiterate something that that Tom said
because it's more than true Tom Moyer
Michael Benedict and their staff are the
glue that holds everything together in
our three categories and we can't thank
them enough I've known Tom before my 21
years as a governor and he's the best
and he does a spectacular job and Tom
thank you again
um
all right all right all right let's get
this party started
welcome to the academy of Motion Picture
Arts and Sciences
the academy Museum of Motion Pictures
and this Splendid theater
to this our annual opportunity to meet
our live action short filmmakers
I'm John Bloom one of three governors in
the short films and feature animation
Branch along with my fellow Governors
Bonnie Arnold and Marlon West
we welcome you
to this nominees
Symposium the third of three we do it
with all three categories and we're
ecstatic to be here today to talk about
this
it's my privilege to introduce our
moderator
for our talk with our nominated short
filmmakers
producer director
Peggy reisky is an accomplished
filmmaker
and she has produced 17
projects including three shorts
produce three films with John sales and
two with Jody Foster
she served as Dean at the Loyola
Marymount University School of film and
television
and as head of producing for the NYU
graduate film program
at the Academy she is a long-term member
of The Producers branch
and recently the head the chair of the
Student Academy Awards
but most impressively Peggy is also an
Oscar winner
for producing and directing a live
action short
and it was and that was her first
directorial effort so that's pretty
impressive
Trevor
Peggy's short film is nothing less
than a milestone in short films
a poignant comedy about a young teen
whose world is turned upside down
when word spreads at school he might be
gay
Trevor
is amongst the most
known successful profitable
and important shorts ever made
and that's to say nothing about its
cultural import
Peggy's essential role
in sequence in in subsequently
forming the Trevor Project
is another important accomplishment
now the largest 24 7
lgbtq plus
suicide hotline
but let me tell you how that came about
when Peggy was finishing Trevor quite
rightfully so they were working on the
end credits and they wanted to include a
gay oriented suicide hotline
and guess what they couldn't find one
and so Peggy did it herself and that
says a heck of a lot about the kind of
person she is
so
Trevor is an exceptional short film
please join me in welcoming its creator
our exceptional moderator Peggy ricekey
[Applause]
good thing
holy moly
it's so nice to be here and I welcome
all of you to what I think is one of the
most special events during the Oscar's
week here at the Academy
um I want to say things to the governors
for the wonderful work they do to keep
the academy going all year long and I'm
so grateful to be able to
welcome This Global representation of
filmmaking in the panel that we're going
to start with very very shortly but
first let me be before we begin I'd like
to welcome our ASL interpreters
um for our program and I know bless you
you're going to be standing here and
taking over
mid-center so it'll be very easy for
folks to see
so without further Ado it's my pleasure
to be able to introduce uh first of all
the filmmaker for the red suitcase
I please help me welcome to the stage
Cyrus nashvod
hey Cyrus
next up is night ride filmmaker Eric
Larson
thank you and welcome
uh next up from France Le papil director
Alicia Aurora and her producer Alfonso
cuella
[Applause]
next up is the filmmaker for evilu
Anders Walter and I'm sorry he told me
American Anders Walter and Rebecca
purjam
maybe um
and last but not least our friends from
Ireland for making an Irish goodbye Tom
Barkley M Ross White
looks like we got some represented
so welcome welcome all
um
I'm gonna start out with a few general
questions and look forward to hearing
what you all have to say in that regard
so let me ask you
first of all these are Exquisite films
really beautiful and they represent so
many things that are quite sensitive
subjects including issues about identity
loss
harassment child abuse
and one of the things I'd love to know
is
when you're thinking about that
how did you think about how this first
of all talk a little bit about why you
felt film was the best way because
honestly I know you have tons of ideas
about possible projects but why was film
the right way to tell the story
and what either research or what did you
do to prepare yourself to take on the
issues that are in the main theme of
your film
so if I may Jens who brought the rain
with them sorry Ireland we did indeed
um yeah thank you for having us here um
yeah we're filming Irish goodbye you
know it sort of it looks at loss it
looks at grieving in the ritual around
grief and sort of being thrown back
together with your family in that
aftermath
um I think we we wanted to explore that
in in a sort of a light way a way that
fell true to life and and looked at both
the light and the dark in those moments
you know we we speak a lot about
um how that moment of grieving you know
those strange instances where you you
have a need to sort of laugh at a
funeral or this sort of bizarre kind of
juxtaposition of feelings and that feels
very true to life for us so we wanted to
explore that in our film and yeah that
was kind of where that came from
our wonderful folks for me the little
Anders can you talk a little bit about
yours
no so it's Eva Lewis based on a Danish
graphic novel
um that was extremely poetic I didn't
think that I was doing or going to do a
film about incest it's obviously a very
dark and tough subject matter but the
graphic novel was so poetic and
really was a direct inspiration in terms
of how to translate this into the into
Cinema language and so there was
something about it takes place in
Greenland of course there's just
something about the way that the nature
impacts the young girl's story that
really spoke to me and and also of
course was very visually appealing and
to place this small individual in such a
vast and epic landscape in order to
communicate that feeling of feeling
lonely
um
yeah and I've told I've done nine films
now and they all deal with with children
in who finds themselves in
a life-changing situation that is unfair
um so yeah I love to tell those stories
that are really um
you know give the children a voice
thank you for that yes please
I think I mean you also asked why we
would do a film about this and I think
this subject matter incest is um it's a
taboo not just in Greenland but and the
problem is not just a green antique
problem it's a taboo and a problem all
over the world
and I think for us putting making it
into a film
in a way it opened people's minds and
hearts in a different way we're so used
to having all these
you know sociologists or politicians
with all these you know documented facts
about this and that are numbers which is
also important but I think making a
movie is a way of
having people change their mind on the
and open up to have a debate and put you
know be able to talk about this subject
matter because that's the only way to
break a taboo is to start a conversation
beautiful thank you so much
we want to also now come on over to Luke
and Alicia and Alfonso can you talk a
little bit about your process yes the
the movie we did it's about the Eternal
question how to split a cake
they serve the cake
and
if we think the cake is everything can
be everything also today the movie is
1943.
but everywhere there is a cake and who
keep the power sorry for my English I
try who keep the power normally wants to
take the cake
all for them
and who deserved the cake the little
girls
the nannies or the people that are
outside the dogs the Chinese sweeper
the Vagabonds chimney so
and I decided to do it into a movie
first of all because Alfonso
and says do you want to make a movie he
didn't tell me you want to make a book
and
and I this I immediately he told me if I
want to to think about make a movie
about
Christmas
and I immediately thoughts about a
letter
and this letter was full of images the
cake
the the Christmas so also the Christmas
the Nativity is one image we play in
front of an image
uh not all play I mean many people play
in front of this image and
um so I told the movie was the best way
to tell this story and also I was very
happy to be free about the length
see so like to use exactly the time I
feel I need to tell this story and this
is the big freedom of a short movie that
you are really free about timing somehow
more than with a long movie
and so I don't know if I answered you
want to say something
the only thing I want to add is my
involvement is that I wanted to taste
her cake
[Laughter]
oh thank you I'd love to now talk to
Eric
and God about Knight ride which is
um well I don't want to give anything
away go ahead
yeah our film is about
um
yeah if you want to go home take a cab
not a straight car
no it's it's yeah obviously it's about
some social responsibility
um
and I would say it was
a natural
um
the the the film is like uh a silent
movie so it it could be you know
um
could only be very visual I would say uh
it's like uh
um yeah Buster Keaton kind of inspired
story
uh so so yeah that was a
it was very much meant to be a film
would you yeah
well you know
should we mind our own business or
should we stand up for all this Night
Riders also it's about
finding courage inside oneself to raise
the voice against any kind of Injustice
and to bring this story
for us I mean we are doing films so
that's what we do and it became a film
and to bring this situation in into a
drum
is doing something with the story
because nobody can escape
and they have to take decisions or and
and the the the the woman driving the
tram had to take a decision whether to
turn her back to everything or to face
the problem
so it's an interesting Arena to to to
shoot on the location
thank you I have so many things I want
to follow up with but I will hold them
for the next round
um and last but not least the Beautiful
the red suitcase
yeah actually in the beginning I was not
intending to do a short movie but at one
moment it went for me very urgent to do
something about it and this happened
back 2019 I was at my parents we were
having dinner and around the
conversation my mother told me that
she's in contact with our family in Iran
and that she heard from her friends her
sister that the women were disappearing
in Iran just because they were telling
their opinion or a woman disappeared
because she didn't put her head her
hijab correctly
and I heard this
and but I hate politics I had all these
things but when I went home
it's like you hear somebody is in danger
and you turn yourself the other side and
you tell to yourself I didn't hear it
and I couldn't
do this
and a few weeks later I said I have to
do something about it I cannot just
leave it like this and I decided then to
do a short movie let's say
doing something you know because around
me all my friends were saying Iran is
beautiful let's go for holidays I said
no it's not like this so
and at that moment I decided to have a
main actress in the movie A girl Iranian
girl with a hijab coming in the airport
of Luxembourg and from there on create a
story where we can talk about the Free
Will of the woman
which is the main thing two years after
really happened you know and back 2019
nobody knew about this so it was for me
some kind of Mission to talk about this
and today I'm relieved because the whole
world known about this so I'm happy
about that you were a question
[Applause]
so let me ask my Irish goodbye
colleagues uh Tom and Ross by the way I
want you to know producers I'm not
overlooking you I can't be one of you
and I know how often that happens
um anyway you know the Irish goodbye for
folks who haven't seen it
um
can I just double check is this are the
visuals in the right order
okay thank you the film follows loss in
a touching and humorous way between two
siblings dealing with grief and
Reconciliation in the in the wake of
their mother's death
and in the film for those who haven't
seen it one of the big issues comes up
is they discover a list of the hundred
things she would have wanted to do in
her life
and that list is the thing that becomes
a catalyst for the film and what helps
bring them together so I wonder how the
idea for that is the driving force for
this for the plot came together and also
would you please talk a little bit about
the casting your approach to Casting
yeah
um so to begin with um Ross and I had
both moved we had been living together
in London
um we had been writing plays separately
and then when we decided that we were
going to pursue filmmaking together we
both moved back to our hometowns and so
there was a theme of sort of leaving
home returning home and being sort of
flung back into the family unit and then
around about that time I'd been to a
football match with my dad and saw two
brothers
um much like the the brothers that end
up in our film adult Brothers very sort
of Burly working class who were sort of
hurtling abuse at each other throughout
the whole game in a very fiery uh
combative kind of way
um but the younger brother had had Down
syndrome and so there was this kind of
juxtaposition of of that brotherly
relationship and then this kind of Duty
of care so they were the initial kind of
catalyst they were the seed we ended up
speaking about these characters for the
rest of the week
and I think initially the the opening
image was uh these two with this kind of
Fairly elaborate urn and carrying around
their mum's ashes and thinking about how
we could sort of take them on a journey
that would take two characters that are
polar opposite ends of their sort of uh
their grief their approach to grief and
their sort of relationship with each
other and and their their family and so
I can't actually remember exactly when
the sort of bucket list kind of idea
came about but whenever it did it really
sort of
um galvanized the whole idea and and you
sort of gave us a very uh real and kind
of tangible uh driving force as you say
to kind of take these characters on on a
journey
and then in terms of our our casting
yeah we we got you know incredibly lucky
I think
it's a you know it's a character study
and and without the right actors and in
those roles it would definitely would
not be here so we've got the remarkable
James Martin who plays lorcan is he here
today I think he is give us a way of
James there he is
congrats
[Applause]
I'll not say too many compliments to
Jim's head gets bigger and bigger but
now Jim says James is a real natural
star um and remarkably the Oscars on
Sunday is Jim's birthday
whoa so he's coming with us for sure
we're gonna have some kick on the red
carpet um but yeah so James is a
remarkable actor we sort of we'd written
like a first draft of the script and
then we I knew a little bit about Jim's
before James is a bit of a local Legend
in Belfast where I'm from but I'd not
seen a market before and then he'd sort
of been in his debut acting role in a TV
film and we both kind of just finished
this first draft we saw James at the
penny dropped so we wrote this letter
begging him to do the job and thankfully
he came on and really bought into the
script and then you know with a sibling
pairing it's really It's Tricky you know
you've got um you've really gotta try
and find that chemistry that sort of uh
similarity you know and sort of uh we we
had these tips and from different actors
and it was we couldn't quite find the
thing and then sheamusohara the
remarkable who plays Turlock in the film
uh the tip came through and it was one
of those moments where as a filmmaker
you just breathe a sigh of relief and
he'd given us everything we'd written on
the page and more and some ideas and it
was just really exciting so look these
two guys are the heart and soul of our
film we pointed the camera at them and
we just stayed out of the way quite a
lot um because we really struck Gold by
finding them well they do say 90 of the
success of any film lies in who you cast
so well done the only question I have is
what was he a legend for legend of many
a thing
um
James's dad actually is a retired radio
DJ in Belfast and he on a very much
beloved kind of Morning Show and he used
to bring gyms on the show uh maybe on
like a Father's Day kind of special or
Christmas day thing and everybody was
like bring gyms on every single day so
James quickly got this cult following
including my own mum who when we'd
written the first draft of the script
said to me what about young James Martin
and so maybe maybe it's her we should be
crediting thanks mom she's the casting
director of this film moms by the way I
just want to share that when I was
asking them in the green room before so
what are you all doing uh what's a
highlight of LA and they told me well we
had scheduled to go um to burping but we
discovered we need covet tests for the
Oscars so we have to go get those today
good luck yes good luck oh
all right and now for uh our folks with
the Beautiful film even though
um the storytelling
as many have described as beautiful and
poetic and it's against a very very dark
plot
and I wanted to ask you all
there is a lyricism to this
and it may now have to do with what you
described as the influence and the
source material for the book but how did
you find the balance
um
which is very very delicate to both
build the relationship between the
sisters and also to very obliquely imply
what's actually going on in the home
front
no it was obviously a balance because
um
and also trying to bring in a little bit
of Hope in this in this very dark story
The Graphic novel that is based upon
does have it even more dark ending than
the film
in the graphic novel Eva Lou hangs
herself
at the military base
and whereas we kind of played around
with the myth of the mother of the sea
which is a famous myth in in Greenland
in order to
you know try and be a bit more open and
poetic about the ending and also we
added the character of the grandmother
who I believe is at least pointing in
some direction of of Hope which is that
the community around these kids have to
do something about it because I think
the most devastating thing when we got
into the research on all of these
victims is
more than 50 percent of and it doesn't
go only for Greenland it's just you know
a universal problem but most of these
kids tend to think this is their own
fault
which is terrible because and that's why
they're not putting up a fight really or
or because they really think maybe they
could do something different in order
not to be raped or abused which which is
terrible so I think the community plays
an important part in anywhere in the
world where this takes place and the
grandmother was really you know that
balance of trying to open up for a
little bit of Hope saying that if the
community or relatives or friends or
anyone who sees or sends this talk about
it or do something about it or address
it because the kids are not going to do
a lot about this because they're
struggling figuring out if they could do
something different in order to get the
love from the parents
um
so that was that was the balance and of
course you don't want to come across in
a naive way because you don't want to
bring in you know too much of a beam of
a light and say that everything is going
to work out for these kids because it's
probably not for a lot of kids it's not
going to work out at all
um so it was definitely a balance
um
um I'm not quite sure who found it I
feel like we did something in order to
to point in some Direction but it was it
was tricky
well I just have to say first of all for
folks who haven't seen it your use of
landscape was Exquisite because that
sense of vast forces so much larger than
you that as a young girl would just feel
like they are waiting you down and where
do you go and you feel powerless in the
face of that was really beautiful and
also just quickly one of your major
characters is a bird
can you just talk about that
I mean the Raven plays a big part in the
green Atlantic mythology and it was also
in the graphic novel
um
and obviously I mean people can
interpret this in many ways but I feel
like the soul of evil who obviously
lives in that bird and will live there
forever
um technical lead was quite a challenge
to do a you know have a bird in there as
a character it is done in many different
ways it's a mix of the birds we're
actually shooting in Greenland just
shooting up in the sky and getting a lot
of great footage but every time it had
to fly from A to B of course we had to
do it in 3D afterwards and then
the third thing was shooting a real
physical film Raven in the Czech
Republic they have a very well-dressed
and trained Raven in the Czech Republic
so we shot that up against the Green
Screen so it's a comp the two birds yeah
yeah they get tired really quick
everyone gets tired okay so it's a mix
of a lot of things to make that work
oh well done well done
um
let me move it I just only worry about
that time I know we could talk to each
of you for an hour
um but with Alicia with lupapiel
um as you mentioned it's inspired by a
letter
that Ferrante had written and that's a
very slight it sounds like bit of source
material which you developed into this
beautiful piece and one of the things
that I wondered about is please talk a
little bit again for those of unseeing
it it is an extraordinary cast of girls
young girls and as you said 40s the war
is going on and also guess who they're
taking care of
by nuns now having been raised Catholic
all the way bib you know grade school
high school May I just say I'm quite
familiar with that world so I wonder if
you can talk a little bit about that
sense of
uh
you bought poignant humor to your young
leads dilemma so
yes the letter
tells just the last part of the movie
The Christmas lunch
of a group of boys
so first things
first thing I decide to change in girls
because I taught girls
has have the power of
split the cake
so this is cooperative so I thought
if I have to tell this story today
they should be girls
I think was important and
I love movies I more love people
and children and I know when you make
movies with children can be very
dangerous for children
so the most important things was to make
them feeling they are really all the
same so there is not one protagonist
this is why we didn't cast
Seraphina the protagonist we cast
immediately 17 girls
all together
and we didn't know for real who is
Seraphina
every one of them could be Seraphina
then for two weeks with
play games it was covered the time so we
we were obliged to spend all the time
together because we couldn't see other
people we test and we are we see we stay
always together
and after two weeks of working with a I
always work with a big friend of mine
that is Tatiana leopard is also an
acting coach
and after two weeks of working we
we saw the character coming
um up like flowers not like coming down
into the children so and we understood
that Melissa is Seraphina
but in the realized moment I thought she
was the best Seraphina and as the
children told that who talks more is
more important
Seraphina is not important because she
just says like
I'm a bad girl so she's not talking a
lot in the movie so they told she's not
the protagonist for sure
and she does yes so and we
um I think for with children is always
very important to be very careful that
you don't the movie doesn't
yes affect them
they in a negative way they they it's a
really a game
it's something very serious for children
but it's a game so it's very important
for me and this is also why when we
present for the first time the moving
can we decide to go with all the girls
together because I didn't want that one
is considered the most important and all
together
so this is how we cast the girl we cast
with a video on WhatsApp because it was
was covered very strong at the time and
we couldn't make a casting so they just
sent we we asked in Bologna in
yes self tapes so we saw a lot of self
tapes and with the nuns I was more free
to choose who I really love to work with
and so my sister Alba the bed none
and wonderful in her in her character
and then I found
actresses I really love
uh of course Mr Rosa Valerie brunette
but Carmen pomel all the other nuns was
actress I really admire and one of them
the most Young
she is an example of child
that was used for a movie
and she was incredible she did a movie
when she was a child and then she didn't
work anymore so I said come come I she's
incredible
and the chimney
sweep are my neighbors
so just because we always need to think
about our neighbors
last year last year and Alfonso what
made you reach out to Alicia
uh I'm a big fan of Alicia
so uh when there was this idea of doing
short films around the uh
end of Year celebrations in different
cultures languages
uh backgrounds religions and so on
pretty much the first the first name
that came to my head was
Alicia and we know each other throughout
the years
so
yeah I had a conversation and the next
morning she called me and said I have a
story says okay let's make it
some things are destined
congratulations you have good taste sir
very good taste
um
and so let's talk a little bit about
night ride
uh you know the film again is a
beautiful blend of seriousness there's a
lot of tension in the film but also
comedic and warm at heart and I wonder
about how
you know throughout the shooting and the
way that you cast the film as well I'm
in its conception of your lead character
I'm wondering if you had in mind about
size was it the actor that inspired you
or was it in the conception
in terms of how you cast the film
no
originally well the the the the part is
is for a woman and we we went to Toronto
because we had to go out of our city to
to film and and I wanted
uh most of the actors at least to to
come from that region so we visited from
them and we had an audition
and so it was an open audition and and
then uh segregama is sigri here today
she didn't arrive yet I think and and
she she did the best audition so it's
natural to choose her
it it turns out that secreted is a
smaller person and in terms of what's
going on I think thematically in your
film the sense of who are the people
that are overlooked and often perceived
as Outsiders sometimes based on physical
parents sometimes based on identity you
have both
in your film which is which was I think
uh so
exquisitely handled and the connection
the people who are on the outside
actually when they find a fellow that
they feel understands them at their
deepest core is one of the things that I
really really admired about your film
and can I just ask quickly about where
did this uh idea of this come from and
is it really that easy to steal a tram I
know you must have gotten this a million
times but my partner wanted me to make
sure to ask okay yeah
so firstly
um good point about uh about
feeling like an outsider and and being
an outside and in a way everybody feels
that in some part of life
or most of life and um and and another
yeah very nice to to have a meeting of
of of those two characters
on on the tram and um yeah in in Norway
it is easy to steal trams
so um and that that was probably the
reason why we had to move from Oslo to
Trondheim because in uh in in Oslo
actually a friend of mine stole the tram
so we do that a lot
and um
yeah but but they're trying to stop that
you see I would hope so to be honest
yeah so so we had to go to another
um city and ruin their reputation which
we hope
yeah I did wonder about the Norway
version of the MTA what they thought
about your film
um and can you just quickly go also talk
about how you both came together to
collaborate on this
well this is actually uh our first film
together and we have a new film in in
the pipeline
so uh we're working hard on other
projects and looking forward to the to
the next film maybe hopefully not in the
tram because from a producer's
perspective to shoot inside a tram it's
kind of scary because it's a lot of it's
moving all the time a lot of noise
and there are windows windows all around
so so I mean the whole crew had to lay
down on the floor inside the tram all
the time actually not to be reflected in
the windows we didn't know what was
going on while while the main character
was driving the tram as this same time
as she was playing her part in the film
and there was a time coming from behind
so we have to keep on going forward so I
mean
logistically uh choose another location
but it works well and here we are yeah
and you got production Insurance a nice
production value and it's nice to have
your producer underneath the seats so
you can like carry on with your work
there's a lot of bonding a lot of
bonding okay thank you
um and now you know Sarah's about the
um about the red suitcase
this is a film which you've already
explained the setup to the audience
about a young woman who shows up
airport Stranger in a Strange Land and
there's this red suitcase and it takes
us a while to figure out what the heck
is going on and she's acting very odd
and we just cannot figure out why and so
I wonder you told us about what made you
want to make the film
and then that this first idea about a
young woman in these circumstances came
to
I wondered how you go about your your
skill with tension
is is quite
quite effective and so I wonder how you
thought about that in preparation as
well as when you got in The Cutting Room
so the first point is to give empathy
to this main actress main character
and when you give this empathy then you
have the audience already
and then you have to bring problematic
for this girl and slowly the audience
will begin to care a lot about her
whatever is not going on her Direction
because you know her dilemma
and and the more problematic you get the
more uh
the audience is caring about her so
that's why at one moment I wanted the
the
man understand that she has a red
Luggage So by audience understanding
this and being very close so they are
very scared so that was to create this
tension till the end and at the end when
she's going away normally the audience
is saying you know and that was uh
there's a motion I wanted from from the
audience this brings us to the editing
the editing was quite tricky because I
didn't want to have an action movie
who says action movie says uh fast
cutting I wanted a movie with action
but slow pace
the slower the pace is
the more the audience is going in the
brain of this girl
so we knew that the pace has to be slow
but if we do too slow then it can be
boring
so we needed to find this good measure
so instead of having two weeks of
editing I decided to extend it and we
extend it to three months
I was always
making uh strangers with test screening
I say strangers to the movie to come and
sit here and watch the movie so they
were watching the movie during 20
minutes and I was watching them
because when you showed the movie after
the the first thing the or the people
are saying in front of the director
who's also the producer it's a very nice
movie it's very good and it's not what I
wanted to hear I wanted to hear the
truth and the truth you see on their
gesture
as soon as they were moving or they were
asking a question about the movie I was
explaining but I was writing down the
minitage where was these things because
I know there was a problematic and so on
so that was the work to find to be not
an action movie and that the pace should
not be too slow so that was the work I
had to do after the editing so that was
your both questions so I answered these
questions I I have lots to say but I
guess we don't have time and what else
would you like to say a lot of things to
say but the usual question is why is the
the title The Red suitcase so you know
and why is it
see
so um I wanted that this red suitcase
should be her heart
so I decided to to to to to add
everything what is in this small red
suitcase because she's from a very poor
family with tender stuff which could
come from this family like this painting
she was doing all these paintings she
was drawing it's with hair you know to
do something with the femininity there
was kitsis inside I put a few tissues
working or I put the small books you
could have or dispersion pistache we're
always the mothers give to the children
you know and then the the suitcase was
full I closed it I gave to another
another one about my main actress I said
look treat this luggage like your heart
and then she didn't know she wanted to
put I said do you put your heart on the
floor no so how I said keep it like this
you know in the exact place where is
your heart and you always keep it like
it's your heart so that's why we try to
keep it like this and then the color was
very easy after it had to be red
so at the end of the movie when the guy
is taking this red suitcase I wanted to
give this feeling that it's her heart
being ripped off
thank you thank you for coming up with a
great question
and now let's bring it back what were
you hoping I'd ask what would you like
to say if you had a perfect interview
question because let's face it you've
all done a lot of press you get asked
the same things over and over when you
walk out you go why didn't they ever ask
me this so Eric go for it ah see
you ask me
you thought I had to continue
[Laughter]
ah I can continue
I'd like to continue on your film
actually
I was joking I finished
um yeah whatever I've I've had all sorts
of questions
um so so probably haven't been asked uh
there's nothing I haven't been asked uh
well I'd like to say something because
because this is a film you know about
um
harassment and and also about uh
uh gay rights and transgender rights
which is is important uh it's important
here but imagine how it is in other
countries where that is forbidden you
know
so so that is important but a lot of my
soul in this story is is about
you know feeling lonely and
you want to connect
uh and and there's there's a Melancholy
to to the story and there's also this
this that life takes you places you
don't know where where you're going it's
uh
um life takes you in unexpected
directions where you feel you don't have
any control and that's a lot of my life
I don't have any control of what what's
going on
um which so so that that's a probably a
question that is a sub theme
um that that I haven't been asked yeah
okay your turn my turn yeah well
well I think it's interesting to say
that that you know the film as you
mentioned actually it starts in kind of
the comedy
and it gets really dark
and it ends with a hope and I believe we
do need stories today with that brings
hope to people uh in in the world today
so so even if we are trying to address
some something that that is difficult
and and and
that we that that is dark but to bring
also some lines see some light at the
end of the tunnel is is important uh and
and that's I guess is what we've been
trying to do
um in the film we need inspiration and I
think you're all these films are
bringing it into the world
um Okay so
Alicia
yes
ah yeah
I have to make the question
oh
what here's two ways you can answer this
or what's one of the favorite bits of
Direction you gave to an actor either
one
uh
with the children we promised at the end
of the shooting they can eat the cake so
probably that was
I'm sorry I always talk about this but
we had the three cakes
one with chocolate and cream one without
chocolate for the dog
and one without milk for the people that
allergic to me so it was very
complicated question in each scene and
he said let's take the cake for the dog
it's always very complicated but
everyone had a
happy no maybe
I think what I love really really love
it's to make meat people that they
don't meet in the life
so like to make a important actors meet
with
um
like for example the Chinese
[Music]
like the chimney Clean Sweep yes like so
non-actors with actors and people that
are used that normally they know they
control themselves with people that can
control children and you know old and
and I love this and sometimes in the
moment I'm
terrified
I'm really terrified for example also in
this short when you have a dog you have
to do this the children have to do this
and the actors and everyone is screaming
and
and say why I'm doing this
like but then I know it's because I love
to see at the end of the movie they say
I am so happy I met this those people
like to make it possible to make this
meeting possible make a movie it's
really to build a square no like all the
people are in this square and they are
in the same place and they can met and
they can and the meeting can change
their life
so a child can change the ideas of an
actor an actor can change the ideas for
example the
non-actors normally they feel ridiculous
no they are like
I don't want to do this but then when
they see the actors that the actors do
everything
with so much serious yeah serious way so
they accept the game
and I think also in this little movie we
did it possible to make people meet each
other thank you so much I'm gonna just
jump to the last two directors because I
see our mites we may be needing their
wrap up sort of soon so if I may can you
talk about either a question you wish
people would have asked that you never
really get a chance to talk about or a
high point in the directing experience
no I mean the high point was was working
in Greenland and doing this in a
different language than my own I'm from
Denmark and we have a whole entire
greenlandic crew here and the two or
three wonderful actors who were in the
film so and it took such much courage
for them to be part of this film on many
different levels
first and foremost because obviously
they want to tell this story themselves
and I totally understand that
so it was a long long journey to figure
out a way to do this together
and then also of course understanding
that for these two girls Mila and nivi
who put their faces to the film this
who's sitting somewhere right here
yep
welcome and thank you
it's it's obviously a very sensitive
thing to do because they come from a
small society and where everybody knows
them or and it's you know it's a it's a
delicate topic matter in Greenland like
a lot of other places in the world but
also in Greenland so to put their faces
to a film and trusting us to do a good
film let's say this film hadn't worked
out and everybody would have criticized
not only them but everybody in Greenland
who helped do this film on on doing it
so they they risked a lot more than we
risked so to have them here and and to
enjoy this together with this entire
crew is for me the the highlight of of
the movie and and being here today and
obviously also on Sunday
thank you I I think it's beautiful to
remind people of the responsibility and
Power you have as directors all of you
and it seems to me none of you take that
lightly
um and last but not least
um well we we do get asked this but I'll
kind of bring it up because it's
important to us but um for obvious
reasons we get asked questions about um
representation in the film for actors
with uh disabilities and learning
difficulties and um I think what was
really important for us in setting out
to make the film was that in in Larkin
was a character that
um had agency within his own story and I
think it's really important that these
characters are not just uh present you
know it's not enough for them to just be
present in the story they have to be
active as protagonists and I hope that
James's brilliant performance in it kind
of shows what what can be done when you
when you kind of entrust
a character with that responsibility as
well
um we don't often get asked who wrote
all the funny bits and it was me
[Applause]
anything you'd like to add
every time he loves that one
to be fairy dead but he wrote that line
you know the English or no crack at all
he did write that one so he's at least
he's self-aware
now you know I think um the only thing
I'd add is you know this is a Northern
Ireland you know people ask about this
Irish amazing Irish year of Cinema and
the I think a quarter of the nominees
are Irish in the acting categories yeah
and uh we we feel very very proud to be
a small part of that but you know
especially representing Northern Ireland
where where I come from and you know I
think um
I think this is the 25th year since Pace
you know since our Good Friday agreement
and Pace in that country and like this
film isn't about that at all and for you
know intentionally so and it's really
it's a matter of Pride for me to sort of
show the place in a different light you
know sometimes we've been known for our
history and it's important for for me
and I think a lot of my generation that
we we show the kind of the charm of the
place and the wit and the heart that uh
far far exceeds the kind of the the
negative history so that yeah that means
a lot
well I want to just
I just want to thank you all again and
what a great conversation thank you for
all that you've shared and I just want
to call back as I wrap up a bit of what
you've said Rebecca which is I think the
beauty and power of film is that it
gives you a chance
to apprehend
versus comprehend comprehend comes later
but what film does is it can cut you to
the quick it sort of circuits uh
bypasses the brain and it goes to your
heart and your gut
and I'm so grateful we have these
extraordinary people here who have done
that so beautifully so thank you all
thank you all for coming go see them if
you haven't yet and enjoy the show